hey guys how's it going so today marks
the first video of my Christmas cooking
series and I'm not really sure how many
there's gonna be I think there's gonna
be a lot I'm hoping that there's a lot
it depends depends on a lot of things it
depends how many times I fail at cooking
it depends how much cleanup there's
gonna be but either way we're starting
this off by making basic gingerbread
cookies now there was a time back in my
old kitchen you guys might remember this
I don't think I'm supposed to actually
be putting this all in yet that was the
first time that I've ever made
gingerbread and it was the early years
of my cooking videos I've learned a lot
since then so this is my Redemption
video we're gonna make gingerbread
cookies now these are gonna be very
special gingerbread cookies because I'm
gonna try to make some of some of my
youtuber friends so these are youtuber
gingerbread cookies no promises that
they look anything like my friends but
we'll save so one of you guys actually
tweeted me this recipe for gingerbread
cookies I tweeted on Twitter that I was
looking for one I was really hoping for
like a home style family tradition
gingerbread recipe but you guys all
thought I was joking and you sent me a
lot of memes this recipe calls for 3/4
cup butter softened so and with all that
being said probably not gonna measure
anything but that's okay it's it's the
effort that counts and I'm putting forth
a lot of efforts like I've got this
freaking thing oh man have a holly jolly
Christmas it's the best time of the year
here's our butter in in you go
for their mixture
[Music]
now I have all of our dry ingredients
we're gonna kind of mix this up and then
I'm gonna slowly put it into the
gingerbread mixture then it tells me
that I have to refrigerate for four
hours or overnight like are you insane
nobody this is a super impressive like
I'm impressed with what I've made its
gingerbread go Wow okay so we've got our
gingerbread mixture which is delicious
by the way now we need to chill this for
four hours or overnight like that's
ridiculous like what a waste of time
just hold this container very strong yes
thank you for your strong body that's a
shame
it really does we're like the horses huh
okay let's wrap this beast up it does oh
my gosh it does look like poop now I
can't unsee it alright I'm gonna put
this in the fridge for hours potentially
overnight we'll see alright we're back
it is way longer than four hours later
it is the next day I've got my lovely
gingerbread dough here it's been sitting
out for actually a couple of hours
because it was quite chilled when I took
it out of the fridge this morning so
we're gonna roll this out and then I
have to sort of figure out who I'm gonna
be making out of all of my youtuber
friends into these gingerbread cookies
I'm terrified for them I'm terrified for
myself I don't know what's gonna happen
but first let's flower of our surface oh
that's a nice
well I guess I'll just roll it out so I
think the first person that I'm going to
make is going to be let's see gonna make
Casey nice chat ok so you look great
hmm so I'm gonna need to make like a
little camera as well for Casey I've got
how am I gonna get him off of this thing
oh yeah this is not working very well
okay oh well sorry Casey
next up my friend ro you guys know ro we
do tons of fun videos together and ro
was like super cute and tiny and little
and she's the best so I'm gonna use the
little teeny tiny gingerbread man woman
for her I hope I can't I see this is
nice because I'm real thick oh shoot I'm
sorry rau yeah there she is that's my
girl
let's do Lindsey Stirling yeah I don't
look bad actually now I need to make a
little violin there's a violin looks
great like a little a little violin
mine's for like the strings next up
we're gonna do jenna Marbles I actually
haven't seen her in a while so Jenna
hello I miss you this is gonna be our
Jenna oh oh sorry sorry sorry there you
are I'm gonna make your little hamster
this is your hamster I don't think I'm
even gonna remember like what these are
there's the hamsters eyes and there's a
smile next up we're gonna do Madilyn
Bailey yeah as I go through these
they're turning out way better
this is gonna be Madeline's microphone
well it's like a microphone it also
looks like Lindsey's violin there you go
that's a microphone next up we're gonna
do Cassy Blogilates Cassy I love your
girl here she is
all right there here's Cassie's yoga mat
I forgot who was who now let's do my
girl Lilly Singh superwoman
do gingerbread expand
oh god this is just this is this looks
like home base okay good enough where am
I gonna put this well I'm out of room so
sorry other friends that I'd planned on
making I'll save this for later and how
to bake these up and then as soon as
they're done we're gonna decorate them
alright the time is now it's been about
10 minutes I would say I'm hoping that
my cookies are done and ready so we're
gonna take a look Oh remember when I was
like oh I wonder if these are gonna
expand oh my god they have all expanded
into each other this was supposed to be
my Redemption video for making
gingerbread cookies Lindsay's violin is
burnt
Casey's camera is turned into a Kris I
don't even want to talk about Madeline's
microphone oh my gosh they're all one
they're all one cookie if memory serves
me correct I think this was Casey and I
sat over here so we're gonna make his
glasses he's always got the sunglasses
on why do I even bother this is
atrocious
I think today Casey decided that he was
gonna be wearing a red shirt some new
fresh kicks he just got back from like a
4500 mile run this morning it took him
only an hour
let's fix her that a vlogging camera
here okay we're drogo we're gonna give
her some cute little eyes today ro
decided that she was going to wear a
very very nice pink dress pretty not all
these inspirations for gingerbreads
these look nothing like anything that I
was hoping it would look like all right
well here's Madeline's microphone okay
well I think this icing doesn't work
Madeleine today she is wearing she's
wearing a very nice blue midriff top and
we're gonna put some nice little white
like a white skirt on her Madeleine also
got a manicure today Oh where's Lily
oh this was her superwoman oh my
goodness can you imagine if I was in a
bake-off I'm
definitely wind Lily like Lily always
wears bread
we can't tell I've given up hope and my
fingers hurt from squeezy icing so maybe
I'll just start writing people's names
on it okay this is Lindsey oh I some of
these icings work better than others so
I will just do Linds
okay there's Lindsey we're jennamarbles
go I made her hamster
Cassie's yoga mat seems like pink is the
only one that works so we're just gonna
use that okay here you go Cassie you're
wearing a button-down let's go over here
I think jennamarbles was also one of my
my gingerbread Mohini assistants No okay
here let's see if this works me Jenna
you're wearing a nice little nice little
pair of shorts here am I gonna have to
do another Redemption gingerbread cookie
video because I had a lot of plans this
is Jenna my sister Jenna not jenna
Marbles fill a very large range of
emotions right now these are my youtuber
gingerbread cookies and what's great is
as a youtuber I feel like we've got a
great community and here we are all
unified hi
[Music]
Oh God smells like it smells like the
fire department should have been here an
hour ago
[Music]
[Applause]
you